raúl siria está a cargo de su hija anna
ahora postrada en cama luego de ser
rescatada al borde de una vida tras
sufrir una agresión por su pareja anna
forma parte de las estadísticas de la
corte de justicia regional de la
provincia de burón a santiago la ciudad
más violenta de ecuador para las mujeres
indígenas donde en 2021 se registraron
mil 252 delitos sexuales tuvo un derrame
cerebral por el golpe que tenía en la
nuca entonces queda en vegetal ahorita
está cinco meses y necesitamos apoyo
realmente
un básico es alimento y es el más básico
79 de cada 100 mujeres de la amazonía
son víctimas de violencia de género la
mayoría viven aisladas y no saben a
dónde acudir lo que agrava el escenario
según las defensoras de derechos las
consecuencias embarazos en niñas
matrimonios forzados abuso y explotación
sexual de vidrios y violencia física
es el caso de auxilio quien también
sufrió y ahora lucha para proteger a las
mujeres indígenas
reclamamos nosotros inversión también
para lo que es el tema de la prevención
atención y erradicación de las
violencias que superponen a la amazonía
con dos puntos porcentuales superiores
al promedio país
promedio el que también se encuentra en
abril a chicas quien logró escapar de su
agresor que era su propio padrastro
abandonada por su madre explorada por su
familia huyó con una de sus hijas hoy
vive en extrema pobreza
yo viví como una esclava
abusado de ese señor
y halagos
a los 12 12 años me quedé embarazada de
primera
la asignación de recursos en el
presupuesto general del estado para
atender la violencia en contra de las
mujeres de la amazonía es marginal sin
embargo auxilio no se doblega en su
misión de conseguir más protección por
ello demanda crear un fondo común anual
con un porcentaje no menor a el 15%
financiado por las regalías de la renta
petrolera y recursos naturales